and
so any he waits any he waits any he
waits for a
call from a
friend the
same it's the same was it always the
same
[Applause]
anyways for the
[Music]
[Applause]
last the
clock never stops never stops never
Waits she's growing
on it's getting
lame
[Music]
and
so he forgot he forgot Maybe
not maybe he's been seriously
Hur could that be
worse head lights CR the hill Shadows
pass by and out of
s
seas and
dreams Friday Bingo pigeons in the
park and he waits for the last
time just the same as the last time
and he
says you
see this is why I'd rather
be
[Music]
alone
so any Waits any Waits any
waits for a
call from a
[Music]
friend the
same it's the same why it always the
same any
wait as
last head Li CR the hill who will be the
one forever
more
he I could
be if we're both to lonely when we're
old
any waits for the last
time just the same as the last time
anyways for the last
anyway but not for
[Music]
me
hey friends wasn't that an awesome spot
uh I love City Center in DC it's a
little ways away from Gallery Place in
Chinatown and
uh I think I've maybe shot there once
before but yeah just I love the lights
down there it's a it's a really Nifty
spot so I'm glad I was able to share
that with youall in this video uh so I
do need to put a huge thanks to ultra
poy for sponsoring this video and giving
me a reason to go out and explore
awesome venues like that here in DC um
if if you'd like to pick up your own set
of those orb poy Pro uh LED contact poy
that I was using in this video you can
do so using the code Drex factor with a
zero instead of an O at checkout over at
ultra.com that helps out both Yourself
by getting a discount and it helps out
the channel so everybody wins once again
that is Drex factor with a zero instead
of an o thank you so much to ultra poy
for sponsoring this video and speaking
of thanks I have more thank yous to
offer specifically uh to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy for helping you make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I've got
down in the description of this video
and special thanks to the non-b business
uh friend of the channel That is peka
beonin uh thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission keep
those and finally U um this video would
not be possible were it not for the
amazing support of the my followers on
patreon in particular I'd love to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right over here uh
right now if you enjoy the videos that I
produce uh and you'd like to see more of
them there's a very simple way to make
sure that happens and that is to go
yourself over to patreon to sign up to
support this work you can do that at
patreon.com drexfactor po every dollar
helps me be able to focus more on
creating videos in the future so go
check that out please and thank you and
finally if you'd like to check out more
performance videos that I've done over
the years such as this one I'm going to
go ahead and leave a link to a playlist
of those videos down in the description
as well as up here on screen uh thanks
so much for watching make sure to get
out and flow yourselves uh today and I
will see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace